but do you think
on the physics side of things you know
there's been uh
recently a few folks eric weinstein and
stephen wolfram that came out with a
theory of everything i think there's a
history of physicists dreaming and
working on
the unification of all the laws of
physics do you think it's possible that
once we understand
more physics not necessarily the
unification of the laws but
just understand physics more deeply at
the fundamental level
we'll be able to start you know uh
i mean part of this is humorous but uh
looking
to see if there's any bugs in the
universe that could be exploited for uh
you know traveling at uh not just
the speed of light but just traveling
faster than our current uh spaceships
can travel
all that kind of stuff well i mean to
travel faster than our current
spaceships could travel you wouldn't
need to find any bug in the universe
right the known laws of physics
you know let us go much faster up to the
speed of light
right and you know when people want to
go faster than the speed of light
well we actually know something about
what that would entail
namely that you know according to
relativity
that seems to entail communication
backwards in time
okay so then you have to worry about uh
close time like curves and all of that
stuff so you know in some sense we
we sort of know the price that you have
to pay for these things
right understanding of physics that's
right that's right we can't
you know say that they're impossible but
we you know we know that
sort of a lot else in physics breaks
right so uh now regarding uh
eric weinstein and stephen wolfram like
i wouldn't say that either of them has a
theory of everything i would say that
they have
ideas that they hope you know could
someday lead to a theory of everything
is that a worthy pursuit well i mean
certainly let's say by theory of
everything
you know we don't literally mean a
theory of cats
and of baseball and you know but we just
mean it in the in the more limited sense
of everything
a fun a fundamental theory of physics
right of all of the fundamental
interactions of physics
of course such a theory even after we
had it
uh you know would would leave the entire
question of all the emergent behavior
right you know to uh to be explored
uh so so it's only everything for a
specific definition of everything
okay but in that sense i would say of
course that's worth pursuing
i mean that is the entire program of
fundamental physics
right all of my friends who do quantum
gravity who do string theory who do
anything like that
that is what's motivating them yeah it's
funny though but i mean eric weinstein
talks about this
it is i don't know much about the
physics world but i know about the ai
world it is a little it is a little bit
taboo
uh to talk about agi for example on the
ai
side so really to talk about
uh the big dream of the community i
would say
because it seems so far away it's almost
taboo to bring it up because uh
you know it's seen as the kind of people
that dream about creating a truly
superhuman level intelligence that's
really far out there
people because we're not even close to
that and it feels like the same thing is
true for the physics community
i mean stephen hawking certainly talked
uh constantly about theory of everything
right uh uh you know i mean i mean
people you know used those terms who
were you know some of the most respected
people
in the in the in the whole world of
physics right but i mean i think that
the distinction that i would make is
that people
might react badly if you use the term in
a way that suggests
that that you you know thinking about it
for five minutes have come up with this
major new insight about it yeah right
it's it's difficult stephen hawk is a is
a
not a great example because i think
you can do whatever the heck you want
when you get to that level
and i certainly see like seeing your
faculty you know
that you know at that point that's the
one of the nice things about getting
older is just
stop giving a damn but community as a
whole
they tend to roll their eyes very
quickly at stuff that's outside the
quote-unquote mainstream well well let
me let me put it this way i mean if you
asked you know ed whitton
let's say who is you know you might
consider the leader of the string
community
and thus you know very very mainstream
in a certain sense but
he would have no hesitation in saying
you know of course you know they're
looking for
a you know uh uh you know a a a
unified description of nature of you
know of general relativity of quantum
mechanics of all the fundamental
interactions of nature right
now you know whether people would call
that a
theory of everything whether they would
use that that term that might vary
you know lenny suskin would definitely
have no problem telling you that you
know if that's what we want right
for me who loves human beings in
psychology
it's kind of uh ridiculous to say uh a
theory that unifies the laws of physics
gets you to understand everything i
would say you're not even close to
understanding everything
yeah right well yeah i mean the word
everything is a little ambiguous here
right because
you know and then people will get into
debates about you know reductionism
versus emergentism
and blah blah blah and so in in not
wanting to say
theory of everything people might just
be trying to short-circuit that debate
and say you know look you know yes we
want a fundamental theory of
you know the particles and interactions
of nature
you